we need to also educate young people
from the time they go to kindergarten
through whenever they stopped going to
school what piece really is and what you
teach them from kindergarten conflict
resolution not beating each other up
because they get agitated but conflict
resolution what is sustainable peace
what is human security which is of
course meeting the basic needs of most
of the people on the planet you know
decent housing access to health care and
education worthy of the name work worthy
of the name that allows parents to
provide for their children and feel some
self-esteem in the work they're doing